VaynerNation, thank you so much for
listening to THE PLANE PROJECT.
I just want to give a huge shout out to serendipity if the
Wi-Fi was not broken on my flight from Sweden
to New York, this would have never happened.
Kind of just got my work done.
Sat and just started thinking and
somehow got ridiculously inspired.
Please bear with me with the quality of the audio.
Obviously I was in the air and in that zone.
I hope you enjoy this new kind of project concept.
Just kind of almost like a rant album.
I'm very proud of it.
I have a funny feeling a lot of you will get
tremendous value out of it.
For some reason I was able to dig a little deeper
than normal with a lot of the content.
I would love to know: which one was your favorite rant? Enjoy this, enjoy this, enjoy this! See ya! - GV.